[Music]
as we continue to look ahead at all the
noteworthy and exciting titles coming in
2024 it's worth highlighting at least
some of the many great black Le projects
along with the return of major action
franchises from Beverly Hills to Miami
and Beyond there's animated biographical
and dramatic releases on both the big
and small screens we're looking at the
most anticipated black Leed shows and
movies of 2024 on this week's what to
watch innocent black men are in
prison I'm in more have to be slain for
America to say enough is enough
streaming on National Geographic and
Disney Plus in February is the
biographical drama series genius MLK SLX
this Anthology show began on Nat Geo
back in 2017 and has covered the lives
of Einstein Picasso and artha no last
names needed this season will follow the
lives of Martin Luther King Jr and
Malcolm X and in the role of Dr King
will be Kelvin Harrison Jr who played BB
King and Elvis a couple years ago and
Malcolm X will be played by Aaron Pierre
who's voicing Mufasa in the upcoming
Lion King prequel they didn't bring up
that we'd be pairing to the last
interview it's an old kgp tactic can you
draw us attention as a
[Music]
couple first up is the Spy comedy series
Mr and Mrs Smith arriving on Prime Video
in February based on the 2005 film of
the same name Donald Glover and Maya
kkin play the title roles who in this
iteration are actually strangers who end
up working for a mysterious spy agency
and have to pretend to be married it was
created by Glover and Franchesca Sloan
who was most recently a writer on Glover
show Atlanta a show by the way that has
earned Glover Emmys for both writing and
directing
sometimes the messenger has still become
the
message another black Le film coming to
theaters is the upcoming Bob Marley One
Love the title rle is handled by
Kingsley benadir best known for hit
shows like the OA and pey blinders along
with playing Malcolm X and Amazon's One
Night in Miami so he knows a thing or
two about playing a cultural icon and
Bob Marley's wife Rita Marley is played
by Marvel star Lana Lynch one love which
tells the story of Marley's rise to fame
until his death in 1981 was directed by
Ronaldo Marcus Green from the Oscar
nominated King Richard and he wrote the
script with a handful of people
including Boardwalk Empire Creator
Terrence winter coming to Netflix in
March is the biopic Shirley Regina King
stars in this one is Shirley Chisum the
first black woman to be elected to
congress as the film covers her 1972
presidential run King is joined by a
Supporting Cast that includes Terrence
Howard Andre Holland and the late Lance
reic in one of his final roles the film
was written and directed by John Ridley
who owns a best adapted screenplay Oscar
for 12 Years a Slave Tashi Duncan she's
going to turn a whole family into
millionaires she'll have a fashion line
a foundation opening in theaters in late
April is the Romantic Sports dramedy
Challengers this film stars dendea as a
one-time tennis Prodigy turned coach who
is married to a tennis champion on a
losing streak to help turn things around
she sets up a Challenger match between
her husband and his former best friend
who is also her former lover drama Mike
fa and Josh o' Conor round out the main
cast with Visionary director Luca
guadagnino doing his thing behind the
camera he also produced Challengers
alongside Amy Pascal and Zenda while
working once again with Oscar winning
composers Trent resar and attakus Ross
on the score remember knock and talk
yeah knock knock Hy P get down what the
hell happened to knock and talk hands
behind your head right now I got this
keep the Bad Boys franchise alive this
year will be the fourth installment
coming in June after waiting eight and
then 17 years between sequels the Bad
Boys AKA Will Smith and Martin Lawrence
are back just four years after number
three bad boys for life which was a box
office success along with Smith and
Lawrence returning as detectives Mike
and Marcus will be Vanessa hudgin
reprising her role from the third
installment and among the new cast
members are rehea Sehorn Ian Gruff and
DJ khed as a character named Manny the
butcher detective Foley you ever read
your own five shootouts St the piece a
lot please tell me he didn't get
arrested again twice but I broke out
streaming on Netflix in July will be the
highly anticipated Beverly Hills Cop
Axel F it's a good year to be wearing a
Detroit Lions jacket and I'm not even
talking about the action on the field
and that's because Axel Foley and his
signature look are back after 30 years
with the franchise's fourth installment
along with Eddie Murphy reprising his
famous role as Axel fans will no doubt
recognize a bunch of people from past
films like Judge Reinhold Paul Riser and
Bronson picho and joining them will be
some fresh faces like Taylor paage as
Axel's a strange daughter along with
Joseph Gordon levit and Kevin Bacon
coming to theaters in August will be the
sports biopic Flint strong this film is
based on a 2015 documentary called T-Rex
about a pro boxer claressa T-Rex Shields
and her training for the 2012 Olympics
she'll be played by Ryan Destiny in this
one with Judy Greer and Brian Tyrie
Henry in supporting roles Flint strong
marks the directorial debut for Rachel
Morrison the first woman ever to be
nominated for a best cinemat photography
Oscar from mudbound and Among The
Producers for the film is Barry Jenkins
best known for directing and co- riding
the Oscar winning Moonlight bringing
some animated flavors to this list and
to theaters in December is Mufasa The
Lion King directed by Barry Jenkins of
moonlight Fame this film serves as a
prequel to The photorealistic CGI
version of The Lion King from 2019 and
the 1994 original 2 of course reprising
their roles from the 2019 version will
be Seth Rogan Billy ikner and John canny
with Aaron Pierre and Kelvin Harrison Jr
stepping in as younger versions of
Mufasa and his brother scar respectively
another Netflix offering this year will
be the drama film the piano lesson this
is an adaptation of August Wilson's 1987
play of the same name and features John
David Washington Samuel L Jackson Daniel
deweer Ray fiser Eric abadu and Cory
Hawkins among the cast a few of whom are
reprising roles from the 2022 Stage
production Denzel Washington is Among
The Producers for the piano lesson which
was directed and co-written by Malcolm
Washington brother of John David in his
directorial and screenwriting d
there you have it some of the most
anticipated black lead shows and movies
of 2024 be sure to let us and your
fellow viewers know in the comments what
you're most excited for whether it was
on this list or not remember to check
out Ron tomatoes.com for the latest
updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay
fresh